John can you give us a few reasons why
people succeeded crop fine um poop you
know i'd say the easiest blanket
statement would be because they set up
their project properly you know and they
strategized it well and they you know it
what people need to think about is that
crowdfunding is very much like making a
film you know that it's a lot of prep
you know and all the the more work you
do in the prep it's going to benefit you
in production that if you prep properly
the production will be much smoother and
if you don't properly you're going to be
scrambling you know and then there's
post you there's the follow-through so
um you know I think being realistic
about who your audiences and how much of
an audience you have and making that you
know sync with your goal and then also
thinking about your audience and
potentially what they'd want from you in
terms of rewards and and providing those
in a crate and providing creative and
interesting rewards you know having a
compelling call to action and compelling
video and being personable and and and
and then you know working it or you know
having enough people on board to help
work it during the campaign you know and
that's you know what I would say you
know do you think people can take their
social media as a collective of the
project and kind of break it down and
say well I'm assuming if we have X
amount of Facebook followers X my
Twitter followers realistically we're
going to be able to get this much think
I mean I think you have to be very
pessimistic you know and really look at
conventional online conversion you know
an online conversion is you know at best
one percent so you know which is very so
if you have 10,000 followers say which I
almost do say so I have eight thousand
followers on twitter and if i convert
one percent of those to even look at
Mike
starter page right so what is one
percent of 10,000 you know I'm a math
guys ten percent is 1000 so one percent
is 100 not much right so if i get if i
do a one percent conversion from my
followers so that's a hundred and if i
get 1% of those people to then convert
from the conversion because the the
first conversion is the cliq the second
conversion is the x that's one person
out of my 10,000 followers who are going
to contribute now I think I'm probably
going to do better than that but if I
really want to be conservative that's
what you're looking at so yes you can
use your followers but you have to be
very conservative about what realistic
about who you're going to convert now I
probably you know will have a higher
conversion rate because I feel like you
know I like to I feel like I followed my
you know 8020 rule and that you know I
feel like I provide a lot of value to my
followers and I think I may be
engendered goodwill amongst them I like
to think and so and I know there's
certain people that I can call on to act
you know and I've contributed to
campaigns etc so you know I think you
know you have to so it's not an easy
calculation when you just put it that
way it's not just saying oh I have 8,000
people so eight thousand people
contributor 4,000 will contribute and
Kickstarter says the average is seventy
dollars so then four thousand times 70
is is forty thousand two hundred eighty
thousand dollars so i'm going to set my
goal aid i'm going to be conservative
and set my goal at 200,000 you know
that's crazytown you know you're not
that's it's not going to work like that
you